Scotland's outgoing first Minister as
tall Sky News she has not heard whether
the police want to interview her or her
husband as part of a long-running probe
into SNP finances police Scotland and
the crown office are investigating how
600 000 pounds raised by the SNP for
Independence campaigning has been spent
in one of her last interviews mrgen also
warned the three candidates fighting to
replace her not to throw the baby out
with the bath water
just before I move on there's also an
ongoing police investigation to use of
funds we wouldn't expect you to comment
on that but there's a suggestion you and
your husband will be interviewed have
you heard anything on that no but I am
not going to comment on I wouldn't
comment on any ongoing police
investigation and I'm not going to
comment on this one so you haven't heard
but
it must have been put pressure on you
and your husband hand on heart did this
play any part in your departure in your
decision no we're going through what I
would describe as necessary Growing
Pains it is difficult but I think we'll
come out of it stronger and perhaps the
tricky thing given we are undefeated
electorally still by some distance
Scotland's biggest political party it's
to get the balance right between the
renewal change refresh that is necessary
I wouldn't be standing down if I didn't
think that was necessary after 16 years
in government but also protecting the
ingredients of our phenomenal electoral
success not throwing the baby out with
the bath water I'm not suggesting that
this is not a difficult process and at
times it has been a less than edifying
process
and Beth joins us now and better how
would you characterize the mood of
Nicholas sturgeon bullish
well Jane I mean it is a extraordinary
time for her in that she has been fast
Minister for nearly a decade next week
she bows out this week she's got her
final first ministers questions her
final cabinet appearance today her final
big public speech and she said to me it
was weird the emotions that she is going
through but in times of how she is
feeling she wouldn't be drawn on three
candidates who she was back in uh what
she thought of the race but I think
within all of that interview there were
lots of warning shots from her saying
things like don't throw the baby out
with the bath water remember that we
have built huge electoral success and
focus on that she she also admitted that
it would have been more normal for a
leader to bow out after a general
election and not now why was she doing
it now she said simply that in her heart
of heart she knew she didn't have in her
uh what it took to go I asked her about
that police probe her husband quitting
as the chief executive
of the SMP uh this weekend over uh
Revelations that the party had lied to
the Press about membership numbers I
asked her whether that police probe had
made a dent in her decision to stand
down now she insisted it wasn't but but
really Jane it was it was an an
interview of a leader I would say that
has thought carefully about what she did
if she has got regrets about leaving
given the mess we're now seeing uh in
the SMP leadership debate with
candidates taking shots at each other
questioning the legitimacy of the
process trashing uh her own record in
government Nicholas sturgeon was trying
to put on a front of I don't regret it
it's time to go a message to the
candidates to say Focus uh on the
Electoral success of the SMP A View from
her uh that with 18 months to go the
party could still do well at the next
election and also an admission from her
that when you are from content Center
for that amount of time you kind of
crowd out everyone else and she her hope
certainly is that her successor will be
able to grow in stature but a very
revealing uh interview she talked quite
personally about her decisions to stand
down she talked about some of her
missteps too I asked her about the
gender recognition bill and the
difficulties she got into over that I
asked you about the case of Isla Bryson
the rapist that was sent to an
all-female prison before being removed
and sent to a male prison and she got
herself in quite difficulties over that
I also asked her about JK Rowling who
had described Nicholas sturgeon as a
destroyer of women's rights and she
talked to me about being a female leader
and being a feminist a fascinating
interview I have to say and it is one of
her final big interviews before she
stands down from Office the new SMP
leader will be chosen on the 27th of
March that's next Monday then they will
be voted in presumably in Hollywood on
Tuesday and on Wednesday morning Nicola
sturgeon will wake up no longer the
leader of the s p and no longer
Scotland's first minister